[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Basic-Video.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich möchte alle Teigarten,
alle Grundrezepte mal als Basic-Video aufnehmen.
Denn da kann ich dann eure Fragen beantworten.
Heute gibt es in meinem Video einen Biskuit.
Denn den Biskuit habe ich noch nie
so wirklich als Basic aufgenommen.
Also wir werden einen Biskuitteig zubereiten
beziehungsweise eine Biskuitmasse.
Ich muss mich da selber immer korrigieren.
Umgangssprachlich sagt man Teig zu allem.
Aber im Prinzip ist ein Teig all das, was man kneten kann,
und eine Masse all das, was eben gerührt wird.
Daher Biskuitmasse, aber Mürbeteig, Hefeteig,
Rührmasse,
Brandmasse
und so weiter.
Beim Biskuit ist es so:
Der Biskuit wird ja wirklich ganz gerne für Torten verwendet.
Er wird aber auch für Biskuitrollen zum Beispiel benutzt.
Und es ist einfach ein superluftiger Kuchen,
der wirklich nur aus drei Zutaten besteht,
nämlich Eier, Zucker und Mehl.
Und dann kann man das Ganze aber auch schön abwandeln.
Ich gebe da noch eine Prise Salz dazu,
mit Kakao, mit Zitronenabrieb.
Und man kann wirklich diesen Biskuit
innerhalb von wenigen Minuten backen
und hat einfach den perfekten, superluftigen Kuchen.
Beim Biskuit ist es so:
Ihr habt vier Teile Ei, zwei Teile Mehl und zwei Teile Zucker.
Das heißt, auch wenn ihr mal kein Rezept parat habt,
könnt ihr euch einfach diese Formel merken
oder ihr könnt einfach sagen:
Zwei Teile Ei, ein Teil Mehl, ein Teil Zucker.
Also einfach doppelt so viel Eier als Zucker und Mehl.
Und dann habt ihr es wirklich schon
und könnt einfach jederzeit den Biskuit zubereiten.
Heute machen wir einen Standardbiskuit, also ganz hell,
einen Schokoladenbiskuit
und dann zeige ich euch noch
die Alternative mit Kokosblütenzucker
und die Alternative mit Birkenzucker.
Die Alternative mit halbem Zucker zeige ich euch jetzt nicht.
Denn im Biskuit braucht ihr einfach den Zucker
wegen des Volumens,
damit einfach die Eiermasse
schön aufgeschlagen werden kann.
Und wenn ihr dann einfach den Zucker reduziert,
dann fehlt euch einfach das Volumen.
Und beim Biskuit ist es auch so:
Auf Backpulver wird verzichtet,
da einfach superlange gerührt wird.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon mal die Zutaten gerichtet.
Ich werde das Ganze, wie gesagt, viermal machen.
Und ihr müsst wissen:
Ein Ei der Größe M hat ungefähr 50 Gramm.
Das heißt, wenn ihr vier Eier habt, habt ihr 200 Gramm Ei.
Und dann rechnet ihr eben die Hälfte davon den Zucker,
also 100 Gramm,
und auch 100 Gramm Mehl.
Beim Schokobiskuit mache ich es dann nur so,
dass ich etwa 30 Gramm Mehl durch Kakao ersetze.
Und das war es im Prinzip schon.
Eine Prise Salz ist jedes Mal noch dabei.
Und ich kann dann verfeinern mit Tonka Wonka
oder mit Tonkabohnenabrieb.
Ich kann es mit Vanilleextrakt verfeinern,
mit Zitronen- oder Orangenabrieb,
mit Likör oder
egal, mit was auch immer.
Das sind die Basic-Zutaten.
Und jetzt geht es los.
Ganz wichtig, bevor ihr jetzt anfangt,
zu backen und zu rühren:
Zum einen richtet ihr euch die Zutaten und wiegt sie vorher ab
und zum anderen heizt ihr jetzt
direkt schon mal den Backofen vor.
Denn der Biskuit muss später
sofort in den Backofen nach dem Rühren.
Also Ofen vorheizen!
Wichtig beim Biskuit ist jetzt,
dass die Eier zimmerwarm sind.
Und ich mache es tatsächlich so:
Wenn ich Eier kaufe,
dann lagere ich die auch bei Zimmertemperatur.
Es steht ja auch immer drauf: "Zu kühlen ab: ...
Zu verbrauchen bis: ..."
Und daher lager ich die bei Zimmertemperatur.
Und Eier sind bei uns sowieso
im Dauergebrauch.
Das heißt, wir haben die immer frisch da.
Und die wirklich schön zimmerwarm lassen,
damit sie sich einfach voluminöser aufschlagen.
In alten Rezepten sieht man auch ganz oft,
dass da heißes Wasser dazu gegeben wird.
Aber das braucht man eigentlich gar nicht.
Und, wie gesagt, auf Backpulver wird auch verzichtet,
da eben alles superlange gerührt wird.
Jetzt habe ich hier die Eier, den Zucker und das Salz.
Und es gibt beim Biskuit
entweder das Ein-Kessel- oder Zwei-Kessel-Verfahren.
Das heißt, zwei Kessel würde bedeuten,
ich schlage das Eiweiß separat auf
und die Eigelbe separat.
Braucht man aber im Prinzip nicht.
Ich habe es früher auch gemacht,
habe es auch im Buch so mit drin,
in meinem alten, im meinem allerersten.
Aber man braucht es wirklich nicht,
wenn man die Eiermasse lange genug rührt.
Und mit lange meine ich wirklich lange.
Das heißt, ihr dürft sie jetzt wirklich
etwa 15 bis 20 Minuten lang rühren,
bis die Masse fast schon steif geschlagen ist
wie Eischnee.
So fest wird es nicht,
aber wirklich ganz lange rühren.
Das heißt auch, wenn ihr einen Handrührer habt,
sehr lange rühren.
Ich gebe jetzt hier bei dem Standardbiskuit
einfach ein bisschen Tonka Wonka dazu
und schalte jetzt die Maschine an.
Ich werde parallel gleich noch
den Schokobiskuit zubereiten,
einfach in einer separaten Maschine,
und habe jetzt hier auch schon mal
meine Tortenringe gerichtet.
Ich backe jetzt gleich 20 cm,
aber aus der Menge könnt ihr auch einen 26er backen
je nachdem, wie hoch ihr eben den Biskuit haben wollt.
Oder ihr könnt daraus auch eine Biskuitplatte backen,
die einfach schön voluminös
und auch einfach schön luftig ist.
Und jetzt heißt es, einfach rühren.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse echt perfekt aus!
Richtig, richtig schön!
Jetzt braucht ihr keine Küchenmaschine mehr
und auch kein Handrührgerät mehr.
Denn der Rest wird einfach so hergestellt und zubereitet.
So.
Ich nehme jetzt nämlich das Mehl.
Ich mache jetzt
– nee, warte.
Ich nehme das Mehl.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal den hellen Teig.
Das muss jetzt auf jeden Fall gesiebt werden,
damit es keine Klümpchen gibt.
[Musik]
Und jetzt am besten ganz vorsichtig mit dem Schneebesen
wirklich von außen nach innen unterheben.
[Musik]
Und da ist jetzt superwichtig,
wirklich nicht zu rühren, sondern unterzuheben
ganz, ganz vorsichtig und auch wirklich nur so lange,
wie nötig ist,
dass wirklich keine Mehlpartikel mehr zu sehen sind.
Und jetzt auch nicht an den Schüsselrand klopfen!
Denn ihr habt die Luft wirklich
mühsam untergeschlagen,
eingerührt.
Und wenn ihr jetzt an den Rand der Schüssel klopft,
dann klopft ihr einfach die Luft wieder raus.
Das wäre echt schade.
So.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt, einfach im Backring backen.
Und da backe ich einfach supergerne in Backringen,
weil zum einen der Teig nicht so lange backen muss,
also man hat wirklich so 20% Zeitersparnis.
Das heißt, wenn ihr allgemein meine Rezepte macht
und eine Springform zum Beispiel habt,
müsst ihr echt eine längere Backzeit miteinrechnen.
Und zum anderen backt der Teig gleichmäßiger
und reißt oben nicht ein.
Das heißt, es entsteht gar nicht erst diese Kuppel in der Mitte,
die dann oben einreißen kann.
Schön verstreichen.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt noch
den zweiten schon gerührt.
Dann kann ich nämlich beide gleichzeitig backen.
Das finde ich bei 20 cm Durchmessern echt immer ganz gut.
Und ihr werdet sehen, der Kuchen wird megalocker
ganz ohne Backpulver.
Hier mache ich jetzt die Schokoversion.
[Musik]
Wisst ihr, Biskuit, das sind einfach so Satisfying Moments,
die kann man einfach nicht in Worte
– nicht mit Worten beschreiben.
Das ist einfach...
Das muss man zubereiten.
Verstreichen
und dann
– ganz wichtig! –
im vorgeheizten Backofen backen.
Also nicht jetzt hier den Biskuit stehen lassen,
sondern der muss sofort in den heißen Backofen.
Ansonsten
– na toll, habe ich jetzt gekleckert?
verliert er nämlich die ganze Luft, die ihr eingeschlagen habt.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Fehler, den viele machen,
dass sie ihn stehen lassen.
Nein, ihr müsst vorher den Ofen vorheizen
und dann direkt backen.
Und hier ist es jetzt so:
Den backe ich jetzt bei 180°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Wenn ich eine Biskuitplatte backe,
dann backe ich die bei 210°C Ober-/Unterhitze
ganz heiß und ganz schnell,
damit sie einfach nicht trocken wird.
Aber hier möchte ich ja nicht, dass die Oberfläche verbrennt.
Daher wirklich 180°C.
[Musik]
Jetzt komme ich zu den zwei Alternativen,
weil eben immer wieder gefragt wird:
"Kann ich den Zucker ersetzen?
Kann ich ihn austauschen? Kann ich ihn reduzieren?"
Deswegen gibt es jetzt den Biskuit
auch noch mit Kokosblütenzucker
und, wie gesagt, mit Birkenzucker.
Ich persönlich muss dazu sagen:
Kuchen ist ja eine Süßigkeit.
Und ich finde, wenn man alles in Maßen ist
und nicht in Massen,
dann ist es auch mal erlaubt,
einfach zu sündigen und was Süßes zu essen,
vor allem, wenn man sich ausgewogen und gesund ernährt.
Und wenn ich eine Süßspeise esse,
dann esse ich sie als Süßigkeit
und weiß dann auch, dass Zucker enthalten ist.
Deswegen bin ich eigentlich
nicht so der große Fan von Zuckerreduzierung
oder auch von Zuckeraustauschstoffen,
weil ich einfach oft dann das Gefühl habe,
dass Menschen denken,
wenn jetzt kein Zucker drin ist
oder eben kein weißer Zucker,
sondern ein Austauschzucker,
oder weniger Zucker drin ist,
kann man mehr essen.
Und, ich glaube, das ist einfach so die falsche Botschaft.
Und bei Kokosblütenzucker zum Beispiel, das,
wird oft gesagt, ist eine tolle, gesunde Alternative
zu weißem Zucker.
Aber auch da muss man wissen, Kokosblütenzucker
hat fast genau so viel Kalorien wie weißer Zucker.
Es
ist einfach auch so, dass Kokosblütenzucker
zwar
– da wird zwar gesagt, dass der Zucker-,
Blutzuckerspiegel nicht so schnell ansteigt
und eben auch nicht so schnell fällt,
aber
man muss wissen, es sind trotzdem Kalorien,
es ist trotzdem Zucker
und vor allem
ist Kokosblütenzucker einfach eine Importware.
Also die wächst ja nicht bei uns,
sondern die kommt einfach aus weiter weg.
Und man muss dann wissen,
das belastet einfach auch die Umwelt.
Und
gesündere und regionalere Alternativen gibt es vielleicht
mit Zuckerrübensirup
oder mit Dattelsirup
– nee Datteln sind auch nicht von hier.
Also es ist halt echt immer so:
Man muss einfach immer abwägen, was man möchte.
Und
ich glaube einfach,
dass man
alle Aspekte beachten sollte
und nicht sagen sollte,
Kokosblütenzucker ist jetzt megagesund.
Denn ich finde,
die Umweltaspekte sind halt doch auch schon wichtig.
Was bei Birkenzucker für mich das Problem ist,
es ist halt auch kein natürliches Produkt
und es hat zwar weniger Kalorien
und dann wird auch noch gesagt,
es soll gut zu den Zähnen sein.
Aber sind wir jetzt mal ganz ehrlich,
ich pflege jetzt meine Zähne nicht gerade mit einem Biskuit.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich gesündere Alternativen.
Und deswegen,
wenn ihr so was macht,
macht es gerne und probiert es auch aus.
Aber haltet immer im Hinterkopf,
ihr esst gerade eine Torte oder ein Stück Kuchen.
Und da sollte man, glaube ich,
nicht auf Gesundheitsaspekte achten.
Außer...
Außer
– und das muss ich sagen.
Außer man muss es gesundheitlich machen.
Wenn man Diabetiker zum Beispiel ist,
dann finde ich es wichtig,
dass man weiß,
wie man den Zucker austauschen kann und ersetzen kann.
Aber ich für mich
als normal gesunder Mensch, sage ich jetzt mal,
der sich bewusst ernährt,
ich backe halt einfach mit Zucker.
Und der kommt aus der Region
und dann muss auch nichts importiert werden.
Und manchmal nehme ich Kokosblütenzucker,
weil er einfach schön malzig schmeckt
und karamellig schmeckt.
Aber Birkenzucker nehme ich eigentlich
nie.
Ich esse dann einfach einen Apfel.
Ja.
Okay. Ich zeige es euch trotzdem,
damit wir das auch haben.
Und ich hatte auch schon mal einen Mandelrührteig gemacht
und da auch diese Zuckeralternativen,
Zuckerreduktion und so weiter.
Könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen
und ich biete es auch immer an für euch.
Aber die Aspekte mal anzusprechen,
fand ich schon wichtig.
[Musik]
Hi, Aylin!
>> AYLIN: Hi!
>> SALLY: Wer durch das Bild läuft, muss winken!
Also jetzt bitte noch mal.
>> SALLY & AYLIN: Hi!
>> SALLY: Da nehmen wir jetzt ganz oldschool
ein Haarsieb.
Und jetzt unterheben.
Also das ist hier die Masse
mit Birkenzucker.
Optisch erkennt man null Unterschied.
[Musik]
Was ich jetzt hier machen werde
– mh, einen Teig habe ich ja mit Tonka gemacht,
einen mit Vanille.
Den mache ich jetzt mit Zitronenabrieb.
Ist nämlich auch sehr lecker!
Ein wenig.
Ui!
Ui, ui, ui, ui!
Und dann auch hier rein!
Woah, das sieht so schön aus!
Ich habe übrigens
– die Backzeit musste ich noch mal nachstellen.
Ich hatte 20 Minuten.
War natürlich viel zu wenig.
Aber ich wollte es nicht übertreiben am Anfang.
Und es waren dann doch insgesamt 30 Minuten.
Es kommt natürlich darauf an.
Einmal auf den Backofen.
Dann kommt es auf die Backform an.
Dann kommt es darauf an, wie groß der Durchmesser ist.
Aber jetzt so bei den 20cm-Formen
waren es bei 180°C Ober-/Unterhitze
in der mittleren Einschubleiste wirklich 30 Minuten.
Und da ist auch wichtig,
nicht zu früh die Backofentür zu öffnen.
Denn ansonsten
sackt er wieder ein, der Biskuit.
Da gibt es auch eine goldene Faustregel.
Die goldene Faustregel besagt nämlich:
Öffne die Backofentür erst
nach mindestens zwei Dritteln der Backzeit!
Also, wenn im Rezept steht
– keine Ahnung –
30 Minuten,
dann öffne sie wirklich erst frühestens nach 20 Minuten.
Also lass wirklich
erst mal zwei Drittel der Backzeit vergehen
und dann erst öffnen,
damit der Kuchen eben nicht zusammenfällt.
Und am besten gar nicht öffnen,
sondern eher optisch mal gucken.
Meistens sieht man es dann auch.
Das hier ist jetzt die Masse
mit Kokosblütenzucker.
Erkennt man direkt an der Farbe und am Duft.
Da gebe ich jetzt auch keinen Vanilleextrakt oder so dazu,
weil
das würde sich so ein bisschen verlieren.
Murat!
Komm herein!
Hast du jetzt den Sturmi vergrault?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> MURAT: Ich gehe jetzt nach Mannheim.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gehst du die Welt retten?
>> MURAT: Ja. Ich gehe jetzt nach Mannheim in den Laden.
>> SALLY: Murat macht seinen Stammtisch
wieder in Mannheim.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also...
>> SALLY: "In den Laden" heißt in unseren Shop.
>> MURAT: Genau, in unseren Shop
nach Mannheim fahre ich jetzt.
Weil, ich glaube, die Zuschauer warten schon auf mich.
>> SALLY: Na klar, warten die!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die sind den ganzen Weg angereist für dich.
>> MURAT: Da können wir schön Kaffee trinken.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Also viel Spaß dir!
>> SALLY: Ja, der Murat ist immer in Mannheim
und ich bin immer hier.
Ich halte hier die Stellung.
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Ich bin wieder da so um...
>> SALLY: Ich mache ein Grundrezept gerade, Biskuit.
>> MURAT: Ah okay.
Um 18 Uhr bin ich wieder da.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Das macht man nicht vor der Kamera!
Ei, ei, ei!
[Musik]
Portion eins ist, wie gesagt, schon gebacken.
Und ich habe nach 25 Minuten
mal eine Stäbchenprobe gemacht,
das heißt mit einem Zahnstocher
einfach in die höchste Stelle mittig eingestochen,
und da waren noch ein paar Krümelchen dran
und habe es dann noch mal
eben fünf Minuten nachbacken lassen.
Jetzt habe ich ihn rausgeholt.
Er steht jetzt hier seit etwa fünf Minuten.
Und jetzt werde ich aber den Kuchen direkt rauslösen,
damit er einfach so eine schöne, glatte Oberfläche bekommt.
Okay?
Also hier ganz vorsichtig jetzt,
damit der Rand schön wird,
mit einem Backformmesser am Rand entlang lösen.
[Musik]
Und ich lasse den jetzt so einfach mal komplett abkühlen.
Ich decke es einfach mit einem Tuch ab,
damit es nicht austrocknet
und dass auch nichts darauf fällt.
Und dann zeige ich euch den perfekten
– hoffentlich perfekten Biskuit gleich.
[Musik]
Also ich habe die Biskuitböden
rausgelöst nach dem Backen
und dann im Ring aber abkühlen lassen.
Jetzt habe ich den Ring entfernt und die Backfolie darunter.
Und jetzt sind sie fertig.
Und im Prinzip könnt ihr Biskuitböden
einfach supergut vorbereiten.
Ihr könnt sie einfrieren.
Und ich finde es halt echt praktisch,
denn man braucht wirklich nur die drei Zutaten:
Eier, Zucker und Mehl.
Und man hat in so einem Kuchen
einfach nur 100 Gramm Zucker.
Und das ist echt nicht viel.
Er ist schnell gebacken.
Dennoch liebe ich auch andere Teige wie Mandelrührölteig,
weil die einfach supersaftig sind.
Aber der hier ist einfach superschnell gemacht.
Und dann kann man so eine Sahnecreme reinhauen
und dann hat man eine geniale Torte.
Einen schneide ich jetzt auf.
Wartet mal. Welcher war jetzt welcher?
Das ist der Schokokuchen.
Das ist der
normale.
Dann ist das der mit Kokosblütenzucker
und das mit Birkenzucker.
So.
Und dann kann man die nämlich
nach dem Backen und Abkühlen
schön durchschneiden.
Am besten sogar einen Tag lang stehen lassen,
aber abgedeckt,
damit sie sich besser durchschneiden lassen.
Dann krümelt es nicht so.
Und dann
– guckt mal da –
habt ihr den perfekten Biskuit.
Hörst du das?
Oh!
>> JOSH: Cool!
>> SALLY: Und der ist mit Tonka Wonka.
Das rieche ich.
Wow, ist der luftig und locker!
Ja,
das war es eigentlich.
Viele nehmen übrigens auch Stärke mit in den Biskuit.
Das muss man aber gar nicht.
Der wird zwar dadurch dann ein bisschen feinporiger,
aber auch schneller trockener.
Und jetzt möchte ich euch noch ganz gerne
– ich will euch noch verraten,
woher ich das ganze Basiswissen habe,
diese
hohe Kunst der Konditorei.
Es gibt nämlich einen Menschen in meinem Leben,
von dem ich alles gelernt habe
und wo ich mir einfach alles voll abschaue.
Und ich schaue zu ihm hinauf und...
Freddie, bitte komm!
Bitte, bitte zeige dich!
Ich will einfach, dass jeder weiß,
dass ich das Backen von dir gelernt habe.
[Applaus]
Bitte komm jetzt einfach!
Sei nicht immer so bescheiden!
[Applaus]
Komm jetzt einfach vor die Kamera!
Er versteckt sich immer hinter der Kamera
[Applaus]
und hat jahrelang sein Backtalent
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja. Das ist schon ganz lange her.
>> SALLY: einfach versteckt.
Und ich wollte einfach, dass ihr wisst
in diesem Basic-Biskuit-Rezept-Video,
dass er der Mann ist, der alle Rezepte kreiert.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, wo wärst denn du heute ohne mich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Danke!
[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen bei Sallys Welt!
>> SALLY: Hey, yo, was geht ab?
>> FREDERIC: Es schmeckt.
So, wie ich hier gerade, als ich dich getroffen habe.
>> SALLY: Ah, perfekt!
Ja!
[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Darf ich auch mal hören?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir ein Torte backen?
>> FREDERIC: Nein!
Ja!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir eine Torte backen?
>> FREDERIC: Du weißt,
ich habe dir die Tortenkunst beigebracht damals.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Ich war jahrelang in Japan.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß.
>> FREDERIC: Ich bin viele Treppen raufgegangen
und habe viele Torten gebacken.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wir backen jetzt eine Torte.
Also das war das Basisvideo, das Grundrezept.
Und
die 1-1-2-Methode beziehungsweise die 2-2-4-Methode
habe ich von ihm.
Und daraus könnt ihr jetzt alle Torten kreieren.
Aber dafür könnt ihr einfach beim Freddie vorbeischauen.
Denn er hat alles auf seinem Kanal.
>> FREDERIC: Und auch dein Backbuch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ausführlich,
ausführlich behandelt mit Schwierigkeitsskalen,
die du mir hinzugefügt hast.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also, falls ihr weitere Basic-Videos sehen wollt,
schreibt es einfach gerne
und ich arbeite gern noch alle anderen Teige für euch ab.
Vielleicht könnt ihr ja schreiben,
welchen ich als Nächstes machen soll.
Das Rezept gibt es bei Freddie,
aber auch auf sallys-blog.de oder in meiner App.
>> FREDERIC: Das gibt es nur bei dir.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich wollte dich halt mal schöbern.
>> FREDERIC: Ich mache Hochzeitstorten nur.
>> SALLY: Ja, nur Hochzeitstorten.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich mache nur...
>> SALLY: Bei Anfragen zu Hochzeitstorten
bitte immer zum Freddie.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, sagen wir einfach mal,
ich brauche so zwei Stunden Vorlauf.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe danach was fertig.
>> SALLY: Und dann mit Figur?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, Figur...
Nennt man es Figur?
Ich würde sagen, es ist Wachs.
>> SALLY: Ich habe die nächste Videoidee für dich!
Du backst eine Hochzeitstorte.
Und eine Harry-Potter-Torte.
>> FREDERIC: Warte mal ganz kurz.
>> SALLY: Und eine Harry-Potter-Torte.
>> FREDERIC: Ich muss zurück.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Ich muss zurück nach Köln.
>> SALLY: Tschau!
Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Eine Harry-Potter-Torte und ein Video?
[Musik]